If you dry it, you can sell it at a very high price as a herbal medicine.
There is nothing figma does.
You can eat meat, of course.
I don't want
to
eat the meat of the bear that killed people, I
don't
want to eat the fur I want to do ballet  I
don't want to kill my
people If I kill people, I'll go to hell If that's the case,
then I'm a special seat It means
that the old man with this tattoo lived in hiding  They haven't found any nearby waters yet,
most likely, even a runner. Perhaps the man who killed your father is still alive in prison.
The moment the money is found by someone,
the utility value of that man disappears
.
I'm the
one who's going to do it, just lend me your wisdom, I'm
a money-runner, and I'm the enemy of my parents
.